انك اقتحام الوزير الاسرائيلي بن غفير
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك صباح اليوم
يشكل تحدي خطير
لمشاعر جميع ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
رئيس جبهه الخلاص المعارضه في تونس يصف
احالته مع عدد من قيادات الجبهه للقضاء
باللعبه السياسيه ويؤكد انه لن يستجيب لاي
استدعاء قضائي والرئيس التونسي يؤكد ضروره
ما وصفه بتطهير البلاد من كل من استولى
على مقدراتها
كيف تتهم موسكو بمحاوله تنفيذ هجمات جديده
موسكو مقتل عشرات من قواتها في قصف
اوكراني في الدنيا القوات الروسيه تشنه
هجوما على محور والقوات
الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره في المنتخب
منظماتنا عديده تحذرون الازمه التي تؤثر
على خدمات الطوارئ في بريطانيا حيث يموت
ما بين
300 مريض اسبوعيا بسبب عدم الحصول على
الرعايه الكافيه على حد قولها ودعت
الحكومه الى الاستجابه لهذه النغمه
الاجتماعيه المتزايده
الى اللقاء